walk me through like this feud
that you've got with dana white who
started it
who's gonna end it how does it end i
want yeah i want to know uh what's going
on with that it all started back in 2000
uh
it started when i was fighting ben
askren
and
he said on a podcast
on mike tyson's podcast that he would
bet a million dollars
that i would lose to ben askren so
that's where it all started and he then
got ben askren to go and train with
freddie roach who's like a legendary
boxing trainer
and was trying to you know do all this
stuff to get him to win and we just
started going back and forth and
i beat ben in a minute and 59 seconds
and dana was just silent he couldn't
believe it of course then his only thing
is
so that he doesn't look like an idiot
it's to you know insinuate that these
are rigged insinuate that these fights
aren't real he's doing anything to save
his ass because i'm beating all of the
guys that were dominant
in his league the the ufc
and so it's a bad look for his whole
entire company and organization so you
know he's smart he's a smart guy super
smart guy
and he's going to do anything he can to
discredit me
but again it just makes the numbers go
up and
it is what it is have you had any
one-on-one conversations with dana
i don't think so no
i have not so all of this is just
podcast podcasts i say this you say that
where's my money yeah okay and now it's
fun for me like yeah because i see how
mad he gets
and i'm just like that that's what
people don't get like when i'm trolling
i'm having i'm just laughing like i'll
literally just be sitting there in my
room on my phone just laughing at like
all the jokes i'm making and i see how
pissed off it makes these meat heads i
call them like meat heads because they
don't know anything or any other emotion
and just like get angry and like react
so it's like it's like they're my
puppets and i just get them to like
react however exactly i want them to
and i'm just always one step ahead so
for me just fun like i see him get all
mad and say all this stuff and like i
just laugh at it because
he's an old fat miserable man
you know
so
it's just funny man how does the feud
end
how do you want the feud to end man
i would say a sword battle to the death
would be pretty dope
you versus dana white
pay-per-view
sword battle to the
death nah i mean
who knows if it ends
it might never end
i think
eventually he's gonna have to
do business with me and let his
ufc champions come over and box me you
know just like he did with connor and
floyd because at the end of the day
money talks and
he's a smart guy he wants to make money
for the ufc so he's going to let a
champion come over and we'll probably do
a co-promotion where i'm fighting connor
kamara usman or whoever it is